today's question comes from robbie in
california
at age five i started piano lessons and
five years later i got a job playing at
a restaurant on weekends
i was paid 60 bucks a night plus tips
my dad said that since i was a minor he
would save the money for me
when i started college and asked for the
funds i learned all the money was gone
i know the account had over eight
thousand dollars in it
how do i move on from the trauma of this
and develop a healthy relationship with
money
i don't think the relationship problem
here is with money
i think you got to say what your dad did
sucks
and there's a period at the end of that
sentence
and then you got to move on um
i'd add one more sentence what he did
sucks he sucks yeah he stole from his
kid
what a scumburger stole from his kid
and let me tell you just tell you when i
say that everybody goes yeah
but when this young man hears me say
that or you say that it's hard for him
to hear it's hard to hear your dad
is a bad guy oh yeah your mom's a bad
lady because we jump in and want to
defend him
well i mean it's just it's just that's
it's against our nature to think that
the person that's supposed to take care
of you screwed you over yeah
but you got you got to say it i often
tell people to write it down and put a
period into that sentence
yeah and then you got to feel it and it
hurts
and then you gotta go make a decision
what you're gonna do next yeah
and so you know what are your takeaways
from this
how do you defeat the emotional scars
and trauma you have to intellectually
get above them
and uh then you feel them
yeah you got to feel them yeah but
getting above them is it's not a part
it's not a money problem
it's a dad problem it's a dead problem
and so what do you walk away from this
learning uh
well hey you're good at the piano uh
people will pay you for it yeah uh b you
uh you know you have the ability to make
money and save money worked hard yeah
you got a good work ethic i mean 10
years old he's at the pianos i'm reading
that right five plus five yeah yeah and
so
um uh uh don't trust your dad with money
yeah we're not gonna give him any money
yeah i'm not gonna trust him with much
anything really
um you know just uh five minutes of our
time maybe but i'm not
not gonna leave my kid there yeah either
uh i can't trust him stealing i don't
know what else i can trust him with so i
mean
he be there with my kid but not leave my
kid there by myself by himself so
um i wouldn't um not until this is not
still something
some kind of noticeable change in the
old man's life because he's crook
yeah um then uh
the other thing is is that you probably
learned a lesson that you do want to
learn and that is
you don't trust other people to take
care of your money now when you're 10
you're supposed to
yeah he's a child but but you can take
that away and go
you know when i'm 40 i'm not going to
let someone take care of my money
blindly that's right i'm going to always
be involved i'm going to always know
where my money is
i'm always going to understand it um no
one's got like
power of attorney so you know i'm in
nashville we're in nashville and
over the years i've become friends with
a lot of uh
folks in the music business they get
scammed they just and
the stories of the guys
that are you know 60 70 years old and
how they got scammed
when they were making big hits because
they turned everything over it's like an
athlete
and they knew this guy yeah and i loved
him and he hung out with my kids and my
family and 100 million dollars later
he took a lot of my money yeah i don't
have any money because i turned it over
to him like this kid turned it over to
his dad
you have to do that when you're ten you
don't have to do that when you're adults
so it's a good it's a good takeaway and
that's not being bitter or that's not
being
toxic or something you know i don't
trust anymore because of my father no
you just don't
you know it's your job to manage the
money and understand what it's doing
you can help get advice from people but
you can't
get a babysitter for your money so
there's been some i've been doing a lot
of reading on trauma the last few years
dave and
um there's two guys dr peter levine and
another guy named dr bessel vanderkolk
they have a description of trauma that
was transformative for me
and it was it's less about the issue
and more about your body's response in
the present to that issue
so what i would tell this young man is
when he's about to do something related
with money and his heart starts racing
just stop for a second and acknowledge
oh my body's trying to take care of me
and then you can say i'm good i
appreciate your body taking care of me
but i know what i'm doing now or i've
got trust here or i've dug into this
account or i'm
and what you want to do is make peace
with your body in the present because
it's just trying to take care of you and
it will take care of that little 10 year
old kid
for the rest of your life if you don't
acknowledge it but we spend so much time
trying to replay what it
has already happened try to edit that
story you can't edit the fact you're
dead stole your money
what you can do is learn to make peace
with your body moving forward that's
interesting your body
reacts as if the same event is happening
again
yes over and over it remembers to warn
you that it could be happening again
and that's why it's a warning mechanism
all day every day
and we even will fall into similar
relationships to people who hurt us in
the past
because our body wants to correct it and
fix it and we'll end up in the same
situation
over and over like i remember when we
were i was a little kid we were coming
home from my grandmother's uh
several mini like a 10 hour drive and i
we came across the top of this hill two
lane road and stopped because the guy
was turning left in front of us
guy came over the hill and plowed in the
back of us i mean knocked us
in the next to total the car wow it was
a bad
car wreck and um it
i that was 50 years ago
yeah and when somebody gets up on my
bumper from behind now
your heart takes off still feel it takes
off that's right that's the same thing
and so there's a century there's a
little part of your brain that's is
going to scan
your environment for a year forever
until you say
oh there it is i'm good i'm in a big
raptor now
right yeah i'm good yeah i'll win this
exchange
yeah yeah but it's just like whoa i want
to get one of those old people bumper
stickers like get off my butt you know
kind of thing you know
get off my lawn you know yeah that kind
of thing and uh it's just but it's all
it's that it's associated with that
trauma your body remembers that
the name of the book is the body keeps
the score right and so
when think about when you uh like when
you're
you know these guys are called up in
their second marriage but their first
wife blew all the money and
stole everything and so they have
trouble trusting the new wife and so
dave we are in a culture that is so
obsessed with new information
and we can shove it all in a frontal
lobe new facts but that
part of our brain that's looking for
threats is still running and running
lizard brain is real
always running until you make peace with
she walks in
holding the checkbook and you go you
gotta go hey
she's different she's new she i trust
her she ain't got the same name
i trust her that's right i trust her she
looks totally different yeah right
and your body will begin to go okay cool
just want to make sure
that she's not a threat and once you
make peace with your body man that's
when your body re
you receive this healing from this
trauma you know that's what happens when
people get their emergency fund
that's exactly right they've been living
on the edge for so long that every
stinking little thing was a crisis
everything i mean every hangnail is a
crisis when you're broke right
i mean every little dinky 50 thing is a
crisis when you're broke but when you
got ten thousand dollars in the bank
it's an inconvenience it's annoying it's
just an annoyance
but when your emotions still go oh god
oh god
and we hear about people who get out of
debt and they say i can't spend now
that's it yeah because they've got a
part of their brain saying you will
never spend again because we remember
what happened last time yeah and you got
to make peace with it
yeah and that's when that's that's why
you're coaching but you can retrain it
because i mean
it requires it requires intellectually
getting above it that's right and and
going
wait facts are my friends as you always
say yeah and so
like you know but you can't you can't
steamroll your feelings but you got to
know i don't know
i mean like sharon when we went broke
she was terrorized
by us being broke yep and so anytime we
do anything that feels like the stuff we
used to do
like we might the alarm sets off and
it's like whoa
chill we've got money there's lots of
zeros and comments
we could just burn that much in the
middle of the floor nobody will care so
it's okay it's okay
okay she has to have to revisit it
that's very interesting the human body
is extraordinary at taking care of us
wow